il s'appelait adrien edwards et gabriel
adam de villiers ses frères et cousins
sont tombés pour la france lors de la
grande guerre qui sont-ils comment sont
ils morts et quels ont été les
circonstances de leur mort avec le
travail effectué par les trois classes
de troisième du collège bourbon
ces derniers sont désormais plus quand
on inscrit sur une plaque commémorative
l'année dans le cadre du centenaire donc
de la grande guerre qui a commencé en
1900 en 2014
donc il ya eu des appels à projet de
l'inspection d'histoire géographie et de
la mission du centenaire
nous avons répondu à cet appel à projets
est évidemment puisque le collège
bourbon qui étant l'ancien lycée
leconte-de-lisle possède dans le hall
d'entrée 2 plaque commémorative portant
le nom de 97 anciens élèves de ce2 se
glisser un long travail de recherche qui
débute en 2013 et qui durera une année
aux archives départementales aux
archives nationales et jusqu en
macédoine
les archives privées sont venus
compléter cette recherche historique l'a
fallu compléter tout ça par des
recherches aux archives d'outre-mer un
ex puisque les feuillets matricule qui
sont la base essentielle pour travailler
sur des parcours de soda parcours divers
deux soldats sont à
ou à la nomme notamment la source
principale est quand même resté la
presse nous avons dépouillé
les cinq organes de presse entre 1914 et
1918 ce qui a été relativement facile
puisqu'on le dira peut-être après
beaucoup de ces jeunes de sept de ces
jeunes hommes et sont issues de dt dit
créole de la réunion au début du 20e
siècle donc des familles relativement
connus qui se permettaient évidemment de
faire passer l'acte de décès d'un fils
nouveau et c'est dans la presse
un travail de recherche complété d'un
travail d'écriture pour mettre enfin des
mots et construire l'exposition les
poilus de tout repos une fois que nous
avons retrouvé regrouper tous ses
documents masse de documents
nous avons fait travailler les élèves
c'est facile maintenant au sein
d'établissements dépouillement archives
lecture d'informations
on leur a fait compléter des tableaux
signalétique de parcours
et puis ensuite il a fallu mettre tout
cela sous forme de récit et la
bibliothèque départementale avec qui
nous avons travaillé nous a proposé
l'aide d'un écrivain togolais qui
s'appelle gustave akakpo et qui est
venue lors d'ateliers au collège pendant
quatre cinq séances aider les élèves à
écrire autrement qu alors vous verrez
que les récits sur les panneaux s'appuie
sur une réalité historique
il s'agit pas d'inventer un parcours
mais l'écriture se trouve un peu plus
peut-être un peu littéraire parfois un
peu poétique et les élèves laisse aussi
une trace de leur sentiment par rapport
à cette histoire
et le hasard d'une rencontre donne
encore plus de sens à ce travail réalisé
dans le cadre du centenaire de la
première guerre mondiale hubert bas le
petit fils d'emile tarnec raconte son
grand père mon grand père émile tanguay
né à saint denis le 7 janvier 1884 son
père d'origine bretonne était fall
ancien sa mère et cousine germaine de
jean chatel sa mère est morte à salazie
il est donc orphelin très jeune beaucoup
d'émotion parce que je suis venu c'est
par le plus grand des hasards que j'ai
pu connaître cette cette exposition au
départ parce que j'étais venu au lycée
simplement pour photographier la plaque
commémorative
de bourbon mort la guerre de 14 et là
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer comme
une maman qui m'a fait part de son
projet de d'exposition donc il m'a
demandé si je pouvais me associé en lui
fournissant ou des documents des objets
j'ai des fourmis les documents des
photos et des photos d'objets également
ne vais pas retenu notamment sa salle et
jean-benoît bien entendu sa ba dinh
d'officiers s'il était officier de
l'armée française et je l'avais fourni
le numéro de la tombe où il est enterré
en macédoine et madame à 100 m eur
gentillesse de pouvoir photographier
cette tombe je n'avais pas la photo
j'avais le numéro l'attend mais le lieu
mais je n'ai avec un à votre bien
entendu sept tombes dont était aussi
beaucoup d'émotion à ce moment là une
exposition enrichie par des collections
privées mais également des collections
des archives départementales
les élèves ont beaucoup travaillé avec
leurs enseignants avec leur enseignante
à partir des documents qui sont
conservés à la fois dans les familles
les descendants de ces poilus et aussi
aux archives départementales et on à
compléter l'exposition du collège
bourbon en mettant en dialogue en
résonance à certains documents des
archives départementales de la période 2
l'immédiate après-guerre sur 97 soldats
de 14-18 nom inscrit sur les plaques 80
ont été recensés et 55 ans ont été
retenus pour cette exposition tant de
récits reste encore à découvrir
même si on connaît peu de choses de ces
réunionnais qui sont partis à la guerre
et qui n'en sont jamais revenus
pour hubert bain cette exposition ramène
son grand père sur sa terre natale
il souhaite désormais que tous ceux dont
le nom ne figure pas sur les plaques
commémoratives des monuments aux morts
de la réunion soit réhabilité